[موسيقى]
انا نظرت نفسي لاخر يوم بحياتي اني تابع
بعون اني استمر معهن اني ما اتركن
بالاطفال اللي عندهم قوه عندهم ذكاء اذا
كنا جنبهم وقدمنا لهم الاهتمام الصحيح
والرعايه الصحيحه لحدائق منهم الطبيب
والمهندس وكافه فئات المجتمع
[موسيقى]
مروه عوض مؤسس مدرسه التعليميه مدرسه
اداره اعمال تخصص اداره 95
تم تاسيس المدرسه بواحد سبعه 2022 طبعا
المدرسه فيها 8 شعب صفيه من الصف الاول
للصف الثامن وفي هلا سته نفتتح للصف
التاسع سبب انشاء المدرسه اشخاص مصابين
اصابات حربيه بلاحظه ضعف قدموا لنا القوه
اعطونا اعطونا حياه بلحظه الاشخاص سليمين
بعد ما مر هذا الموقف حبيت اقدم لهم شيء
حبيت تحطوا بصمه في المجتمع فقررت انشاء
هاي المدرسه انها تتضمن جميع الاطفال
الضحايا الحرب
هلا التجاوب الاطفال رائع جدا في عندهم
انتفاع كبير للمدرسه في عندهم اندفاع كبير
للتعليم صار في عندهم هدف صار في عندهم
حلم صرنا نحن نستمد القوه منهم هني مجرد
انه اقبلوا على المدرسه فبدي عندهم عمر
جديد يوم جديد
جميع الاطفال
رائع من قبل تعاون المعلمين مع الاطفال من
قبل جلسات حوار مع الطفل مطوله من قبل
التواصل دائما مع الاهل متابعته الحالي
ومتابعه شديده
من اول يوم بيجي فيه الطفل على المدرسه
مباشره بكون في تقييم له التقييم بيكون
كبدايه نفسه وضعه الاجتماعي وضعه الصحه
فمن خلال قاعده بيانات كامله بتشكل صوره
عن كل طفل عنا طبعا نحن حافظين بشكل كامل
كل الاصابات اللي عنا كل الاوضاع للاطفال
فيتم التعامل مع كل حاله على حده تعاون
كتير صعب للاطفال نحن عم نتعامل معهم كجو
اسره
صار في صداقه بيننا بين الطفل وبين معلمته
مباشر مجرد الدخول للغرفه الصفيه فالطفل
بتجاوب معك بحب يفرجيني انه هو انجس خلال
النهار وطبعا احنا على ثلاث شرائح شريحه
الطفل اليتيم تختلف اختلاف كلي عن شريحه
الطفل المصاب تختلف اختلاف كلي عن شريحه
الطفل المصاب بالشلل
[موسيقى]
الاطفال المصابين كل يوم عم نسجل حالات
جديده بسبب الحرب المستمره اللي ما انتهت
لحد الان
فالمعلمين بهذا الامر ما عندهم اي احصائيه
دقيقه للاطفال
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه للاقبال على المدرسه فامتلقت
المقاعد الصفيه ما يقارب 80% طبعا احنا ما
ياسنا ولسه عم ندور على حالات خارج المركز
في كثير من اولياء الامور ما عم يقبلوا
على تسجيل ابنه للمدارس في عندهم فكره انه
الطفل هو معاقب جسد ووجه له رساله انه
الاعاقه هي بالعقل ما هي بالجاسات ونحن
مستمرين بالتسجيل لاخر يوم بالمدرسه
الاهالي اللي اطفالنا اقبلوا لهاي المدرسه
كان التعليقات ايجابيه جدا هي اعطتنا
القوه هي اعطتنا الاستمرار اعطتهم الامل
كمان انه طفلهم رجع متل ما كان
[موسيقى]
ما في تمويل حقيقي للمدرسه طبعا للمدرسه
انشاتها بجهود شخصيه الساده عم بشتغل بشكل
تطوعي
الشنعه يخليني استمر او تعوي بحاجه لهذا
المكان لهاي المدرسه ومحبته هدفي اني
اخلاق منه شيء قوي
[موسيقى]
طبعا خدمات اللي قدمها غير المنهاج
التعليم الاساسي عم نقدم خدمات المسرح
بالاضافه للتاهيل بالاضافه للدمج تعمل
نفسها من خلال التعلم اللعب دائما نربط
التعلم باللعب والانشطه بتكون مختلفه
متنوعه حسب اعمال الاطفال
طبعا انا بحلم انه المدرسه تكبر اكثر من
هيك انه تتوسع اكثر من هيك انه تتحقق
احتياجات الاطفال اكثر من هيك سبب وجود
التطوعين الاحتياجات الاطفال ما تامنت
بشكل كامل فانا بتمنى انه تتامل بشكل كامل
انه تكبر المدرسه متوابح
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]